we're here with harpander singh a
partner at innovation endeavors
and the ceo of slice thank you for
joining us thank you emily it's pleasure
to be here so how did you become an
entrepreneur
so my journey is a little bit different
from most other entrepreneurs
i met my co-founders at stanford
business school
back in 2000
and we were working together on a
business plan before we graduated and
that idea did not pan out but we really
enjoyed working together as a team so we
were essentially a team
before an idea right and we all decided
to
commit six months we decided to say no
to the jobs
and we invested some of our own money
and went through a structured search
process for about six months we looked
at a few different spaces several
different ideas
and our
benchmark was can we get excited about
something ourselves and
you know do we want to spend the next
six seven years doing it so that's what
we did we created a company called fiber
tower it was a wireless infrastructure
company which we built and
sold
after about six to seven years
and we took some time off and the same
team came together
and we did the same exact process looked
at a few different spaces few different
ideas and
created slice out of it and the common
theme was we
at that time felt that wireless was
growing a lot
and e-commerce receipts were growing and
we felt that data would be very valuable
so that's what we've done two times now
so how do i determine that my idea is
the right idea to build a business
around
you know so as an investor
and as a founder the answer may be
somewhat different
as an investor i am definitely trying to
see
is this
potentially a big market a high growth
market does it give you enough room for
exploration
and for errors so that's one thing
that's important and then the second is
do you have some defensibility at least
for a few years till you create room for
yourself
and as a founder
there's a couple of other factors that
become important i mean as a founder
it's not always
clear from the beginning is it's a big
market is this like your mega market and
so on so you generally want to pick big
markets but
you're picking problems that you can
relate to personally
and i like to
pick problems that have some kind of
defensibility around technology around
or around the data component so you want
to create some barrier
that the guy sort of across the street
just can't do overnight
so should an entrepreneur
find a small niche or think big from the
start
you know it depends on how you define
niche um snapchat is niche right
instagram is niche but these are big
companies
um
i think there's a couple of different
ways to think about it i have friends
who have acquired small companies and
you know 10 million revenue companies
and grown them to 30 50 million dollar
uh revenues and grown the ebitdas and
they've created a lot of shareholder
value um i think the traditional silicon
valley would look at that and say hey
that's not
big
um so if you're thinking technology if
you're thinking silicon valley
especially if you're thinking about
raising venture capital
then i think the bar is different
people are looking for billion dollar
plus outcomes
and there
by definition
you're looking for big markets uh
ability to accumulate large user bases
and so on so it really depends on
what your strengths are
are you
are you more of an operator
that wants to optimize are you more of
an innovator that wants to sort of
create magic
and have this thing that that can just
sort of grow to be something
unimaginable um and their trade-offs um
you know it depends on
how much capital do you want to raise it
depends on what kind of employees will
you attract
how much ownership will you retain
and really what is the
core competence of the business is it
design and product is it operations is
it sales so it really i think there is
no one answer to this people have
created a lot of shareholder value
from what might seem small versus you
know what seemed like mega hits